Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today you will see history in the making.
Yes, we are going to have a look at AlphaFold
from DeepMind, perhaps one of the most
important papers of the last few years.
This is a true gift to humanity. And, if
even that is not good enough, it gets better,
because today you will see how this
gift has now become 200 times bigger.
So, what is AlphaFold? AlphaFold is an AI that is
capable of solving protein structure prediction,
which we will refer to as protein folding.
Okay…but what is a protein
and why does it need folding?
A protein is a string of amino acids, these are
the building blocks of life. This is what goes in,
which in reality, has a 3D structure. And that is
protein folding. Letters go in, a 3D object comes
out. This is hard. Really hard. For instance,
DeepMind’s earlier AI programs were able to play
hard games like Chess, Go, and Starcraft 2, and
none of these AIs were a match to protein folding.
Yet, it has become the world’s
best solution at the CASP event,
I’ve heard DeepMind CEO Demis Hassabis
call it the Olympics of protein folding.
If you look at how teams of scientists prepare
for this event, you will probably agree that yes,
this is indeed the Olympics of protein folding.
And what is even more incredible is that it has
reached a score of 90, which means two amazing
things. One, in absolute terms, AlphaFold 2
is considered to be about three times better than
previous solutions. And, it gets even better, the
score of 90 means that we can consider protein
folding as a mostly solved problem. Wow.
This is not something that I thought
I would be able to say in my lifetime.
Now, we said that this is a
gift to humanity. Why is that?
Where is the gift part here?
What makes this a gift?
Well, a little after publishing the paper,
DeepMind made these 3D structure predictions
available for free for everyone. For instance,
they have made their human protein predictions
public. Beyond that, they already have
made their predictions public for yeast,
important pathogens, crop species, and more.
I also said that AlphaFold 2 is not the
end, but a start of something great.
I promised to tell you how it improves over
time, so here are two incredible revelations.
One, we noted that AlphaFold will likely help
us fight diseases and develop new vaccines. And
hold on to your papers, because this is not
just talk, this is now a reality today: look,
this group was already able to accelerate their
research work a great deal due to AlphaFold,
in fighting antibiotic resistant bacteria. They
are studying how to fight deadly bacteria that
modify their own membrane structure so that
the antibiotic can’t get in. That is a hugely
important project for all of us. They noted that
they have been working vigorously on this project
for 10 years, and now that they have access
to AlphaFold, they could get a prediction done
in 30 minutes, and this is something that was not
possible to do for 10 years before that. That is
absolutely incredible. This is history in
the making. I love to be able to live through
times like this. So thank you so much
for sharing this amazing moment with me.
So this was one project, and what is this here?
Oh yes, these are some more
of these AlphaFold predictions
that were already referenced from other scientific
research papers. This is making big waves.
And two, this gift to humanity has now
become bigger. So much bigger. Initially,
the protein prediction database they published
contained 1 million entries. And now, if you have
been holding on to your papers, now squeeze that
paper, because they have grown it from 1 million
to 200 million structures. That is 200x within
less than a year. Wow. So just imagine how many
more of these amazing medicine research projects
it will be able to accelerate. I cannot even
fathom how many lives this AI project is going
to save in the future. What a time to be alive!
Here is the distribution of the data
across different categories, and these
small circles still represent what was available
before, and the big ones show what is available
from now on. Absolutely amazing. It seems
clearer and clearer that we are now entering
the age of AI-driven art creation, but it
might also be possible that we will also
soon enter the age of AI-driven medicine. These
tools can help us so much! How cool is that?
So, does this get your mind going? What would you
use this for? Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!